9 вечора в рапорті бур із їжі носили
так і відомості сет пасажирі і як
пластичну хірургію гірш
впав в Україні про те годинник на
знайомства склеєні в нього не буду лише
приїхав пружно ти голова час на об'єктив
а то я вже порвав дивних сухих
марлевих зон бойових дій дітей давно не
стану палестинців єгиптян
площа тахрір я люблю людей і до
допомагаю їм так що можемо доктор гірш
гидко запрошення український глава
дейнеки сильні на вищі вода світло червоним
вдалі володіння деякою liqueur привіз з
собою чому ящик інструментів то
приладнавши на 25 тисяч євро
австрійський фахівець проти там у
інституті ортопедії до рублів пересадку
мені до їх тканих бійців ато володіння тут
довідки шлюбу я на захід вони голки
повстання але вона вливалася гривні
quick справі мікрохірургії з регістрів він
адже перемога я коротко
чашку за дата волонтери до чи допомагає
каріння чим може наприклад
аль нас пивз основність облава денова
фонду за пиво руку познайомилася хата
темрява активістам з різьблених караян Європи
ти порвані з пильного ж цілям і
привозять в Україну тофа hectic
гуманітарну допомогу для корито
хворих бітті на ebay шадо допомагає фонду
активісти знімає чини так машину
ярослава збитки запам'ятав і розуму не торгую
машина сповнена думою супер завантаження
toyz богдан сказав кожний сечовий
потім німецькі за ветеранами україну
гарніше як завмерла мішками гарніше вони
кожну порошинку шкіряні вільно та
Вільям страйк сауни в саван і за
vantage жили Ярослав падала в капелюх
майже дві тисячі кілометрів
знімайте q це польську мыт на тему
проблемний blew out українською
застрягши через спробую тегами ну-ка
помітне коріння загорнуте з США
рецепт щоб свічки максимальну шведку
він мав і венеції розуміти і ще без
прийняв та ще ми їхали бітуму та вода
читають на цю ніч він вжив а у
стива наживка з вижив його та гуманітарку
і знімає чим ця франція мало вже давно
розван теж ти розумних і лише для хворих
і матеріал для пров'язування ран і
вкрай активні операції мікроскоп на
тому є машини swan теж маша 4 днів
простий гавкіт на кордоні ми для пі
розводити руками за крим до ночі різних
панелек святий але призначається у наказі
міністерства соціальної політики
карає що приходить до млина на
даються документи подає сам це
декларація і до того ж з діснеєм екрану
форму
так все не так просто для там ще яким
цей звір на пропуску монетарного
багажу в краю ну по ви не знайдете
документ з різьблених міністерств та мін
екології та мінсоцполітики держав на
ліки служба щось навчити укр
а там волонтери скажіть тремтіння ванни кого
пальці
з оформленням документів українською від
але служб баки бутика інж організації
хочеш його було зроблено і далеч на
теплою десяток туру витрачено їх до
команді необхідні для них там уже
законом самій роботі 82 шляху жарт я
лише на хвилину валіть усі документи обидва
яким зречусь українцю зла на дорогу
17 травня такого на офіційному рівні
pro c пак індіанці теж у волонтерів на
моєму шоу виходить як вчора запарина ти
приберу до різних кіган і ну а g за
кожним таким по перцю стати реальною ж
до пацієнтів лікаря гірша почистила адже
без проблем та сміх за вас ти в україну
ми точно обладнання
тунельної взятої заборони на українських
суду тиль
таруса